hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Resident Evil 7 now
I thought I was done with this for now
but as many of you know I am a man of
persistence and I have a head bigger
than my ego and I know that I can beat
this and I have a good strategy for it I
was already doing it in the last video
but I just want to beat this because by
all accounts everybody is saying that
this is the hardest challenge in the
game if not for the sheer memorization
of it and trial and error but it
actually legitimately is hard because at
the end of this you have to fight a boss
fight with only being able to take one
or two hits
depending on how you get hit and all
culminating in an area where you have no
resources and nothing to your name so I
want to beat it so I'm gonna give this a
few more tries even though I know for a
fact that I've been having a lot of
problems with this but I now know what
boxes are bums I now know where the
traps are so long as I'm not stupid and
don't rush things I will be able to do
this there's no reason that I can't do
this we're gonna pull Mulligan on that
one I didn't get good drops in the
beginning anyway so try again
[Music]
see remember I said at the top of this
so long as I'm not stupid well huh I
should have known better I should have
known that I am just full of beans all
right now I've made progress so dodge
this traffic then use go up here and to
do this one you don't even need to waste
a bullet you just need to stand over the
trap and then drop down the hole it
works out really well from some reason
that one lasts longer because it's
designed that way all these [ __ ]
traps literally you just got a drop back
up back up or back up or back up okay
and then open this anything here I don't
think there was ever anything in here
doesn't like to have anything in here
for some reason and then whoosh over
here check over in this corner good box
ok so I did blow up the one by the door
right I didn't forget about that I did
blow that one up so then everything else
can actually be taken out by this
machine gun here and it's really
convenient because that helps me out
because everything will just
automatically die when they come
charging for me no protect me
yeah it's died ahead oh [ __ ] yeah do not
you're going down
you're gonna play that game
goddamnit you not
got him down so what we're gonna have is
we're gonna have people crawling down
but what I what I didn't do last time is
I didn't actually set off the bombs when
I needed to set off the bombs when they
crawled under it would have saved me
quite a bit down play
bleh Bubba
little further come on go for it you
want it I know you want it
alright there we go okay so they're done
so now I got the two Crawley bastards
around the corner whoa okay running
running running running do not do not do
not do this go dad for you those guys
are my worst nightmare every time but
we've officially made it a little
farther than we did before I just got to
keep an eye out for traps I've already
taken care of the thing behind that door
so I know that's not gonna kill me and
then she's good to go out right yeah
yeah I know I unlocked it I didn't okay
so I definitely got that that would have
blown me to smitheroons okay I'm pretty
sure no other traps are places if he's a
straight shot out right
that sounds that can I do or do not lag
now
you closed that okay anything out here
anything out here that wants to kill me
probably everything just double-check
the area make sure
so we've officially made it farther than
we ever have before I've still got the
problem a margarita
[ __ ] okay that's why there are moms
there oh [ __ ] oh God
well hey hey you you came out of nowhere
oh boy
I hope I got it I was wondering why
those bombs were there whoo okay well
that's a lot of you guys that wasted a
ton of my ammo [ __ ] I just burn a
little more maybe
well okay you know okay you dead okay
dead dead dead dead is dead dad is dead
can be oh no no no no I hear that I give
that here that you scampering little
bastards where are you
give me a clearing I made a goddamn
clearing No
No oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy no no no
did I get you I just have to replace it
with oh god damn it risk it oh [ __ ] off
[ __ ] you dude [ __ ] off so hard with you
is that all of them okay so are we done
with the [ __ ]
finally Jesus Christ I've walked through
here before there weren't any
there weren't any things getting in my
way so that better not be any now okay
well alright we've made it this far okay
so hopefully there's gonna be some
restocking happening here okay one box
I'll take it box psychostimulants great
what is that gonna do me I'll just take
him to see if there's any Ernie area
there's some stuff down there
another shotgun great exactly what I
needed all right whatever
well this is dead now so I'm just gonna
get rid of this okay Jesus all right so
there's one thing down there that I can
see I can only imagine that as soon as I
drop down and I'm gonna look before I
drop for any bombs [ __ ] stupid biomes
the Marguerite's down there that's what
I assumed just assume I see that I see
that okay
okay strong for it Said's not gonna do
me much good if I die in one hit just
clearing these out cuz I don't want to
deal with them I'm pretty sure
Marguerite starts when you go up the
stairs right that's the whole deal that
wouldn't have done much for me but I
don't want to risk it
great psychostimulants exactly what I
need oh my favorite thing alright so
this is it this is now or never this is
uh this is all the beans okay alright
here we go
I got you right in your stupid face
okay so I've got to get to a clearing
[ __ ] okay that's interesting to know
okay where is she that's the question so
there's a turret in there I just gotta
know where she is so I don't get sprung
now I'm afraid to move
oh boy okay moving where yep there's
your crotch oh boy
okay all right okay whatever you say so
there is a turret in there which I might
be able to use to my advantage but not
hard sure about that hi would I got a
flamethrower that's all I got basically
like that well I'm officially out of
ammo that's fun
okay oh boy okay what did I just get
whoo boy oh wow
ow where the [ __ ] did that come from
whoo that's a thing get that open it up
what is that what is that what is that
enhance gun ammo maybe where you going
from triggered a van
skin shot oh ok hello
whoa okay gotta move gotta move gotta
move gonna move whoa no god damn it are
you [ __ ] kidding me Oh God
I'm alive apparently don't know how oh
god oh god okay this is good oh boy why
are these still up here that was [ __ ]
ridiculous
I cannot believe I survived that very so
if I can dance around this turret that
actually benefits me a lot [ __ ] thought
I heard her
oh boy oh boy
show me dead ass already then that's
weird
for pathfinding is all over the place
well it took a couple potshots at her
crotch whoa that was a good old thump
but I am completely out of ammo okay
she's on the way upstairs okay I don't
think there's any items left in the
house so I'm just gonna have to try to
there might be one more yes that's not
an item in there II don't like that okay
where is she
okay then alright well I'm just gonna
you know go down this way again boy god
damn it's not gonna take any shots at
her the only problem is I just don't see
where oh I see where it is now okay
she's coming right behind and she she's
right behind me cool boy poor boy
hi-yi okay got some on her whoa hey did
I do it
Hey oh my god holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I did
it right down to my last bullet I only
had a knife to my name holy [ __ ] I did
it yeah okay oh damn I did it what I
don't get a reward for that Jesus House
insanity man I was sweating bullets that
whole time so I I guess that's it I
guess that's it
cuz man how is crazy am I on my own I
might play the whole game on the hardest
difficulty because I've heard that
there's uh no man I heard there's a
madhouse difficulty that uh it's just a
complete nutter nightmare to get through
anyway so I'm still just like adrenaline
is pumping me so anyway so that is it
for Resident Evil 7 for now there is
more DLC coming but it's not coming
until the spring so if it does come and
when it does come I want to keep playing
this Resident Evil 7 is really special
to me not special to me like oh it makes
me feel butterflies in my stomach
I'm saying it feels special because it
feels good the feel of the game is good
the movement is good the shooting is
good the action is good the environment
is good so that it leads you into like
this nervous like tense situation where
you're always running out of everything
that you need and anything can kill you
at any moment
it adds that element where in like
amnesia and slender and five nights at
freddys you don't have any defense but
in this one it balances the lines so
well between having defense and still
being helpless like it's it walks that
line
very well and I love it for that I
really really enjoy this game a lot it's
not perfect by any means but God if they
continue with this aspect for all the
games they've got an amazing amazing
series waiting for them now whether or
not the DLC was worth all the money
because one volume cost 10 bucks one vol
costs 25 bucks
oh whoops that's half the cost of the
actual game I don't know if this
qualifies but it does add some
replayability to it and I like that a
lot they did some good stuff here they
should you know credit is given where
credit is due and I'm not wanting to
suck ass of any game company but it's
pretty good and I like it a lot so thank
you everybody so much for watching I
will see you in the spring with this
game again once that DLC is released so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]